[Music]
oh yeah we got new carpet yeah
so this this is uh I mean this will be
something that we like reveal next week
but you're getting early access to it
this is what it looks like
kind of change the vibe in here a little
bit it does a little bit I like the
moodiness of it I actually like that it
kind of like brings everything down a
little bit adhesive
yeah it's more cohesive for sure
um and it does so like
the ship has had this very distinct
smell
every week I beam up and it smells like
somebody left trash out like there's
trash somewhere underneath a bench or
something that somebody hasn't found and
it's just been rotting for like weeks
and weeks and months and months and
months
and
people assure me like there's nothing
it's just the way that or I think you
you made me feel like it's me a little
bit you're like it doesn't smell I
definitely
I have not I don't I didn't smell it as
much as you did and maybe that's my lack
what do you think uh I think you're
right when you say when you every time
you get here it smells really bad
it's me
no I think that when you walk in you
know what it does smell I think you're
correct actually is correct no no now
that you say that my car smells the same
my house kind of smells like it so
no I definitely get like wafts but you
guys leave trash in my car in my house
as well
no but I actually think that a big part
of it was the carpet because there was
that mold yeah from the moment that was
also like black mold like the fact that
we've been just sitting next to that
yeah me specifically because I was like
two [__] feet from it yeah for just
months for hours
every week probably not the safest thing
in the world
so I probably have some sort of like
lasting health issue from that so I'm
happy that we switched it out probably
it's too late probably already have
whatever it was going to give me you
know some sort of chronic disease that
I'm gonna find out about later
hopefully not though knock on wood you
know
so I'm happy that's gone and uh this I'm
happy this is here
it is it's much more like emotional yeah
I feel like but it's good it matches the
chairs too yeah like I like that there's
kind of like tonally similar but like a
little bit different you know yeah
so that's exciting big developments here
in the ship okay let me show you these
two videos okay your ideal life you
picture it okay right
uh actually the first one will be your
ideal weekend
cool picture it in your head yeah
and then picture and then watch this and
think about how much better this is for
sure
four-year-old bachelor in DC on Friday
night I had some good friends over the
house for a dinner party where we had
some pizza for Mandy's and I took on the
role of Resident mixologists for the
night by making some simple cocktails I
love having smaller House parties
there's such a great opportunity to
catch up and have memorable
conversations on Saturday I met up with
my work crew at Dolce Vita for brunch
where I had their pancakes they were
absolute fire I'm very blessed to have
some of my closest friends be the people
I work with absolutely fine afterwards a
few of us headed to Whole Foods to pick
up some Libations before heading back to
my friend's house to chill in the shade
and break some chops for a bit however
the mammoth storm forces inside where I
observed Nature's wrath and then headed
home after a peaceful stroll through
Metro Center I decided to do a deep
clean of the house and have some
leftovers for dinner before doing a
personal Netflix and chill with some
true crime as the backdrop on Sunday I
made a nice hearty breakfast in the
morning before heading out to play
Langston golf course with a few buddies
there you go where of course we had a
friendly competition it was my first
time playing the course and it was truly
a great experience I played decently but
I could not shape the ball the way I
wanted to and my team could not pull out
of Victory though it was just great to
get out there and play for the first
time in a long while and hang out with
some great friends after golf I hustled
home got rid of the Hat here and headed
over to the DC comedy loft where I saw a
live performance of one of my favorite
podcasts we met at Acme the panelists
had some great insights I love the venue
and the show is just a fantastic
experience all around I really hope
Lindsay comes back to DC for another
show soon Cody no exaggeration and with
no changes to that that is your week
literally you like 280 that was every
single thing was you
yeah that's I mean I feel like he's a
little bit more normal though
like I feel like I was like he
he [__] drank in the morning on like
a Saturday and then went home and
cleaned his apartment right I've never
done that in my entire life
the cleaning part
yeah
and then he said personal Netflix and
chill which means he watched Netflix and
jacked off that's true
when he said personal Netflix and chill
out okay
he definitely doesn't know like what
that means I know that's what I'm saying
I love it
yeah I feel like I'm a little bit more
of a degenerate than he is or was at
least
um
yeah
so but yeah I just I I like this normal
guy content you know
nothing he said was like a hot take
or even a take at all no
it's just like yeah my team couldn't
pull through this time and uh really
liked the show hope she comes back
actually that was kind of like a little
he was kind of throwing game a little
bit at the end there he's like he comes
back hope Lindsay comes back because
I'll be hearing my blazer
I'll be sitting front row once again
lens
let me know if you want to have some
mimosas with my boys
um okay and then so okay so if this is
if this was me this is what the next one
is what I aspire to be okay
this is the life I aspire to have
those are cigarettes
[Music]
I hold on I have one more from him
those are cartons of cigarettes
wow
and then we saw it wow
so this is all this guy's videos that's
all he does is eat smoke and drink like
at the same time
so that's what you aspire
yes in another life Maybe
you know when your kid is born yeah no
yeah no definitely not that but in an
alternate Dimension what's the food of
choice in your you got your smokes I'd
be in [__] China or whatever he is
and I'd be eating that [__]
you know whatever that looks so good I
don't know what it was really five
plates of delicious [__] yeah it looked
really good
you watch that and you're kind of
envious of someone that like doesn't
care about health that much yeah
you know what I mean like he must feel
like [__] every day up until that point
where he eats drinks and smokes and you
can tell by that sigh where he goes
oh [__] today sucked you know
in another dimension Maybe